ومن نابلس ينضم الينا الان المتحدث باسم
الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني الدكتور عبد
الجليل حنجل دكتور اولا هل تمكنتم من
الوقوف على معلومات اكثر بشان ما حصل في
مركز جباليه
تحديدا اهلا بكم نعم في الحقيقه كان مركز
جباليا هو مركز الاسعاف كما تقوم الهلال
الاحمر فلسطين بنشر مراكز الاسعاف في
مناطق مختلفه كان هذه احدى المراكز
التابعه للهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني بعد توقف
الخدمات الصحافيه في تلك المنطقه بسبب وقف
الوقود بالكامل وعدم دخول اي وقود لتلك
المنطقه تم استعاده الخدمات ب خدمات
اسعافيه في هذا المركز تحت اسرار ال
الموظفين بتقديم الخدمات الانسانيه تم كان
هناك 127 شخص في هذا المركز ما بين مسعفين
واطباء ومتطوعين ومرضى ونازحين تم حصار
هذا المستشفى وانقطعت الاتصالات بيننا
وبينهم البارحه وصلنا خبر اقتحام المركز
وفي ليله متاخر في ليله ل المتاخر وصلنا
خبر انه تم الافراج عن بعض طواقمنا في
الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني بعد الاعتداء على
بعضهم والتنكيل بهم والتعذيب وتم احتجاز
حتى الان هو يتم اعتقال ثمانيه من هؤلاء
الكوادر ما حصل حقيقه في تلك المنطقه هو
طلب القوات الاحتلال للسكان حول هذا
المركز بالتوجه الى هذا المركز تحديدا
بصفته مكان للنزوح توجه السكان الى هذا
المكان ومن ثم حاصرت القوات الاسرائيليه
هذا المكان وطلبت بالسماعات اخراج جميع
الذكور اولا وبعد فتره تم الطلب من جميع
النساء بالخروج ولا نعلم اين هم واين
وجهتهم واين جهتهم الان غير معلومه
بالنسبه لنا اذا ما زالت طواقمنا افرج عن
عدد منها وبقي ثمانيه قيد الاعتقال حتى
الان وما الجهود التي تقومون بها فقط حتى
يعني نتكلم عن هذا الموضوع ثم ننتقل الى
الجانب الانساني تفضل هل هناك اي جهود
مثلا تواصل مع الجانب الاسرائيلي من
جانبكم بحيث يمكن تامين اطلاق سرح هؤلاء
خصوصا ان جباليه تستهدف بشكل مكثف اليوم
نعم نحن نتواصل مع الصليب الاحمر الدولي
دائما ونقوم بارسال كافه التقارير وتقارير
الانتهاكات بحقوق بحق طواقمنا الطبيه لكن
على ارض الواقع الامور ما زالت
ضبابيه لابعد درجه سواء كان بالانقطاع
الكامل للاتصالات او حتى بالتواصل مع
المؤسسات الامميه او حتى بالرد من قبل
قوات الاحتلال للاسف يعني ما زالت الامور
ضبابيه كثيرا و وحتى لدينا نحن مدير ايه
مركز اسعاف خان يونس اكثر من 30 يوما وهو
في الاعتقال ونحن لا نستطيع الوصول اليه
فبالتالي الامور صعبه في هذا الاتجاه ولا
يوجد هناك اي استجابه من قبل قوات
الاحتلال حول تطم على الاقل الاطمئنان على
هذه الطواقم او معرفه اين هو مصيرها واين
هو دكتور دكتور عبد الجليل لنتكلم ايضا عن
موضوع كنتم حذرت منه وهو موضوع الامن
الغذائي وانتشار الاوبئه بشكل كبير في
القطاع ما الذي يمكن ان تخبرنا عنه بهذا
الخصوص وجهودكم في هذا الخوص نزح 1.8 حسب
مليون فلسطيني من الشمال الى الجنوب حسب
التقديرات وكانوا يمشون على على على
الاقدام لم يكن بحوزتهم الا ملابسهم
الشخصيه لم ي لم يحملوا ملابس غذاء او اي
حاجيات خاصه بهم تكدسوا في مناطق الجنوب
تحديدا فمثلا لو تحدثنا عن رفح 250 الف
عدد سكانها تضاعف هذا العدد اكثر من اربع
مرات فبالتالي هنا نتحدث عن تجمع عدد كبير
جدا من السكان في مناطق النزوح في مناطق
مغلقه خاصه مع دخول البرد والامطار التي
زادت من الامور تعقيدا فبالتالي هناك
صعوبه في ال توفير الغذاء خاصه ايضا مع
العدد القليل من الشاحنات التي تدخل
البارحه دخل حسب ما ابلغنا تواكبنا في
معبر رفح البري 78 شاحنه فقط التي ادخلت
الى قطاع غزه هناك صعوبات حتى بعد ادخال
هذه الشاحنه في الاتص الاتصال والتواصل
وتوزيع هذه الشاحنات عبر الوكالات الامميه
او الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني بسبب انقطاعات
الاتصالات هذا اولا ثانيا ايضا التوقف عدد
كبير جدا من المنشات الصحيه التابعه
لوزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه 52 مركز رعايه
اوليه توقف من اصل 72 مركز هذه المراكز هي
مسؤوله عن صحه الانسان كبير السن وصغير
السن والتطعيمات وغيرها كلها توقف ايضا
انكشاف شبكات الصرف الصحي بسبب القصف و
تدمير مربعات سكنيه بالكامل ايضا منع
الشرب بسبب وجود عدم وجود مضخ سولار للمض
لتوصيل مياه الشرب كل ذلك يؤدي الى تقليل
من المناعه وزياده في الامراض تم رصها
منظمات صحيه شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور عبد
الجليل حنجل المتحدث باسم الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني من نابلس